I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Are you ready for some conniving and some backstabbing? It's the coup.
It's a little bit McBethy. I think that's a term. Look it up, McBethy. Season 3, Episode 3, written by Paul Lieberstein and directed by Greg Daniels. You know what I would really love? What? A summary? Guess what, Angela?
I have a summary. By the way, why did I say that almost like Cookie Monster? A summary? I don't know. Here is my summary. It's a little bit like Stacey. Oh, it is. It's got some Stacey undertones.
We're all Kevin. It's a little Cookie Monster mixed with Kevin. Here's my summary. Michael gets into hot water with Jan after she catches him throwing a movie Monday in The Office neglecting work. So egged on by Angela, aka Lady McBeth. She convinces Dwight to undermine Michael by meeting up with Jan in an attempt to steal the manager position.
You're going to see a whole new side of Steve Carell that is almost in this episode. At the same time, Kelly convinces Pam to have a fashion show, fashion show, fashion show at lunch. Fastback number one. So this is a very, very big Rainn Wilson, Dwight, Angela, Michael episode. When you say this is like the three of you are really driving this episode. I mean, we have this weird love triangle, if you will. I feel like.
Yes. I mean, it's true. I feel like I'm in love with Dwight. He's in love with Michael. Yeah. It's weird. Well, we really wanted Rainn Wilson to come on the podcast this week and Rainn Wilson wanted to come on the podcast this week.
But guess what? If you can believe it, we had some technical issues that kept us from being able to make that happen. However, Rainn Wilson did send in some audio clips and we're going to sprinkle those in throughout. So he will be making an appearance, although very soon he will be making like an appearance appearance. I'm so bummed about the dang Wi-Fi of it all.
You guys, it gets glitchy, it gets glitchy up in here. I don't know, what am I even talking like? Am I 21 in the club? What am I doing? Glitchy up in here? Oh, baby, that's not 21 in the club. It's not. I mean, I hope it's not.
Is it? Is it? It's getting glitchy up. You think when you're 21 in the club, you talk about glitchy Wi-Fi? Glitchy up in here. That could be your undies in a wad. It could be anything. All right, all right.
You know what I'm saying? Fair enough. Glitchy up in here could mean a lot of things. But apparently, when you're 48 in your converted tough shed that you made into an office, you say, is glitchy up in here? We are so sorry that it's hashtag glitchy up in here, but we're going to figure it out. We're going to figure it out. So listen, my fast fact number one is that even though this episode is the love triangle
of Michael Dwight and Angela, there was a big internet stir. As the kids would say. Do they say that? Do they say there's a stir? Pretty much. Pretty much you and I have our finger on the pulse of the hip lingo. Do they say the internet, the internet was a stir? The internet was a stir with the fact that this episode has the first Jim Caron flirt.
Oh. Oh, I know. Oh, Angela, the internet was a buzz. Was it a buzz? Well, you know what? I like the internet was a stir. All right. What I'm going to say now is glitchy up in here and the internet was a stir about it.
Oh, dull face. Oh, dull face. So yes, the flirt begins the distance between Jim and Pam is growing. They are not in touch. Even though Jim does bring Pam up a couple of times in this episode, the message boards blew up. Do you remember that after this episode came out? A lot of strong feelings.
A lot of strong feelings. A lot of strong feelings. Remember Rashida? Jim and Karen. Rashida was like, I'm going to go into hiding. People hate me. Except that she's so cute in this episode. She's so stinking cute.
And you know what? She doesn't know about Pam. It's not her fault. That's right. She's not doing anything wrong. People were like, just hating on Karen, but it's not, Karen's not doing anything wrong. Yeah. I mean, do you think Jim ever told Karen about Pam?
Probably not. Why would he bring that up? Why would he bring that up also for some weird reason the only person Jim ever really confides into is Michael? Yeah. So no, he did not tell Karen about Pam. No way. All right.
Well, this is leading me into fast fact number two, Angela, you have a fast fact for us today about Karen. I do. I have a fast fact about Karen. So Karen's name, Karen Filippelli, was based off an NBC exec named Rachel Filippelli. And this is just a classic Greg Daniels move that he loved to use people's names that he actually knew. I feel like all of our writers would probably pitch names of people they already knew.
But Rachel Filippelli wasn't an exec and Rashida said she actually met her. So Karen Filippelli was based off Rachel Filippelli. Greg did that all the time. If you knew Greg, you better bet your name is going to end up in one of his shows. Also part of fast fact two, Jenna, I don't know if you remember this, but Rashida would sometimes spill things on set. And she got the nickname of Spillipelli. I don't remember that.
Spillipelli. Oh, that's amazing. That's amazing. All right. I'm going to move us to fast fact number three because this is a huge fast fact. Angela, I don't know if it's that people are spending a lot of time at home, but this week we got a lot of mail from people that was very long, very involved, a lot of deep dives, a lot of conspiracies.
And I'm going to go into this conspiracy sent in by Susie Kowalski. This is the Jim Halpert sleeve conspiracy. You got my attention, Susie. Here is what Susie says, guys, I took a deep dive on Jim's sleeves. As you have done on Kelly's hair and shirts, someone please tell me why for all of season three, Jim's sleeves are not rolled up. He is famously known for rolling up his sleeves, yet in season three they are not rolled and he is even sometimes wearing a blazer.
Here's what Susie says. I believe it's love, stay with me for a second. Oh, gosh. She wrote, stay with me for a second. Go on. She says, Jim's iconic look is him with his dress shirt sleeves rolled up and never wearing a blazer, even though the rest of the men in the office do. However, when Jim moves to Stanford, he's either wearing his blazer or his dress shirt
with his sleeves not rolled up, which is weird because also Andy does not wear a blazer. But after the merger, Andy wears a blazer every day in Scranton. Oh, Susie. Oh, Susie. All right. Susie also says, this is also seen in season three, episode three and four, not two because that's the convention, five, six, seven and eight. Eight is the merger where Andy suddenly starts wearing a blazer all the time and Jim keeps
not rolling his sleeves. But since he's quote unquote home now, you would think he would go back to his old ways, but he doesn't. It's not fancy Stanford, Angela. It's not. Okay. He keeps not rolling his sleeves even when he gets back to Scranton. She says, even in episodes nine, 10 and 11, even when in 11, he's in the warehouse handing
Karen the lease, he's back in a blazer. But why? It continues in episodes 12 through 21, not 22 because that's beach day and episode 23. Guess what? Season four, episode one, no blazer, his sleeves are rolled up. I repeat, the sleeves are rolled up, people. Jim is back, baby. And this is her conclusion.
I believe Jim's sleeves are directly correlated with his dating of Karen and not dating Pam. I think when he moved to Connecticut, the sleeves were his way of starting a new chapter. Maybe it's symbolic that he was never comfortable with Karen. He couldn't be his real self and roll up his sleeves. But in season four, episode one's cold open, he's comfortable again. He rolls up his sleeves and we know at this point, he's dating Pam. Let's give her a clap. Susie, that is some serious sleeve tracking.
I applaud you on your attention to detail. Susie asked if this was intentional or an accident. Susie, this was intentional. Susie, I'm telling you, you are making some ladies in wardrobe really, really happy. They did a lot of things like that. They would change our wardrobe depending on what our characters were going through. And wow, Susie, I am so impressed. We're going to see a lot of moments from Pam where her wardrobe changes or her hair
changes because of who she's dating or what she's up to. Some work, some don't. We do that in life, right? We try on new looks. They're not all winners, guys. They're not all winners. Well, listen, we're all stuck inside. We're wondering what are we going to do?
Maybe something you could do is re-watch season three of The Office and look at Jim's sleeves. See what Susie saw. Let me tell you something, Susie. From here out, I'm going to be looking at his sleeves. Yeah. All right. Fantastic, fast facts, lady. All right, guys.
We're going to take a break. And when we come back, we're going to break down the coup and get ready for some sweet audio clips from Mr. Rainwilson. Okay, we're back. We've got our cold open. Michael and Pam are popping some popcorn in the microwave because guess what? It's Movie Monday. I guess that means we find out in this episode that Michael makes everybody go in and watch
a movie or maybe a medical video or maybe an episode of Entourage. I have to tell you at 42 seconds, Jenna, your look to camera, when you said that they ran out of like instructional videos and you watched a medical video, your pause and look to camera is absolute genius. Oh, lady. It was so good. You know, we got a lot of mail of people asking, why did I pause and look at camera? Because he made you watch a medical video.
Okay. So I watched this with my daughter and she was like, mom, what is, what's the deal with the medical video? I was like, imagine they ran out of like videos related to paper supply or work related videos. And then he just found one on how do you give someone a root canal? And you had to watch that. She was like, ugh. And I was like, exactly.
Exactly. Also, that look to camera that you're talking about, that is in the script. It says Pam looks at, gives camera a look like, can you believe it? Oh my Lord. It was so good. Well, you know, Michael says this is the only cure for the Monday blues. And then he goes into his cabinet lady at 13 seconds. He goes into his cabinet into his safe to get a copy of varsity blues.
Do we need to revisit all of the things in his cabinet? You know, I saw Pringles, I saw the rubber chicken that has to be in the safe. You know. Yeah. There's a blue pack of gum. Here's the thing, his silver tea set that was in there during Dwight's speech. Where did it go? I don't know.
He had to move it for his movie stash. There's more than one movie in there. There's also a new photo of Jan taped over the old photo. The old photo was a picture of Jan like from a newsletter when her last name was still Levinson Gould, and now there's some other photo, but I couldn't, I couldn't catch it exactly what it was. I like to think that it's a photo he took of her that she didn't want him to take. Oh, 100%.
Well, I have a little something about this cold open. Sam, will you play Mustang? What's going on? And now it's time for Kinsey tidbit. Hey, look who got her kids in on it. All three of them. We had to make a sentence so they could all have an equal amount of time, so it was fair. You guys know how it is with multiple children, it all has to be fair or somebody gets their
feelings hurt. So we got a Kinsey tidbit. I have a Kinsey tidbit about this cold open. Jennifer, did you know that in 1999, I auditioned for Varsity Blues? What? Oh, yeah. Yeah. What?
I did. I auditioned for the part that Allie Larder got of Darcy Spears, the cheerleading captain. She was known famously in this movie as the character who comes out in a whipped cream bikini. Oh, my gosh, whipped cream bikini to Mox, who was played by James Vanderbeek. Yeah. She seduces him in a whipped cream bikini. That's the role I auditioned for.
I did not get it. So there you go. Lady, I have questions. Yeah. Go. Did you have to do any cheerleading as part of your audition? Or the fact that you had been a cheerleader, was that a plus? That was a plus.
Did it come up in your audition? It came up in my audition, yes, that I had had cheerleading experience. I think it's probably, I was such an unknown nobody. I think it's probably how I got the audition because I was, I could imagine my agent at the time who was like, she's from Texas because it takes place in Texas. She's blonde. She was a cheerleader. Yeah.
So I got the audition and I had like my Texas accent and everything. I did not get the part. It's okay. But I had read the sides and I remember being like, whipped cream bikini, how does that stay on? Like, how does that, how does that work? And this movie, Varsity Blues, I had to go see it because I had to see, you know, the role I didn't get.
And there are so many things that if you're from Texas, you're like, okay, whatever. That's a, that's a bit much. But one of my favorite lines that my friends and I used to say to each other was by James Vanderbeek and his Southern accent. As the character mocks, he gets into a fight with the football coach who's played by John Voight. They had some like big names in this movie and he looks at him and goes, I don't want your life.
Yeah. We would say it to each other all the time. All the time. Hey, what's up? I don't want your life. Okay. All right. Relax.
How did you feel when you did not get the part? Were you super bummed or were you relieved that you didn't have to wear a whipped cream bikini or both? Was it a mix? I think it was a mix. It was a mix. I was like, oh, I think this is going to be a big movie. You know?
Yeah. And I never. This is a game. That would have been a game changer. Game changer. I never got to audition for movies. I was just really just going in on commercials. That was my big success as I had done a commercial about potato chips that gave you anal leakage.
So this would have been a big deal. Pretty much on camera, all I had said was, wow, and then took a bite of a potato chip. So it would have been a really big deal. But I didn't get it and that's okay. And that is my Kinsey tidbit from the cold open. I love your Kinsey tidbit. I thought that was very, very good, Kinsey tidbit. Thank you.
Thank you. We also had a fan question about this cold open Angela. We had a lot of people ask, what did we do with all the extra popcorn? Because Pam pops a bunch of popcorn and then no one takes it. You guys, we ate it. And we also just put it out on the snack table for the crew. We did eat all that popcorn. It was great.
I'll never forget it. Yeah, we were excited about popcorn. We had a lot of snacks all the time, but all of our snacks, they had to be very quiet snacks because the snack table was behind the walls of the set. So our crafty people, they couldn't pop microwave popcorn because we were shooting and it would make noise. Remember, we had that one cappuccino machine for like a hot second Angela, but it was so loud and it kept ruining takes because people would go back and fix themselves like a frothy
cappuccino while we were trying to shoot and they were like, get that machine out of here. So this was, I mean, to say we were tickled to have some like microwave popcorn, we actually really were because it was usually all things that made no noise. Yeah. Like a lot of our snacks were like cheese, a lot of cheese, a lot of cheese. Guys, don't worry, Angela did not string it who had time for it. I don't have time for that. So I guess Pam also shares that they watched an episode of entourage six times, which episode
I wish we knew. And Jenna, did you know that our lovable curmudgeon, Rainn Wilson, was a guest star on entourage? No he was not. Oh yeah, he was Rainn. This delighted me so much. Rainn was in season two, episode nine, the episode is called, I love you too. He played RJ Spencer, who was an internet comic expert and he interviews Vincent Chase at basically the San Diego Comic Con because get this, Vincent just got the big role of
Aquaman. Okay. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. And so RJ Spencer is going to interview him. But during the interview, Jenna, he starts talking about, I heard that you were engaged to Mandy Moore and she broke up with you, you know? And guess what?
This pisses Vincent off. Oh yeah. Then he calls him an a-hole. This is not the interview he was expecting. No. He calls him an a-hole and he storms off. And RJ is like, I will ruin you, I will write horrible reviews of Aquaman. You know, you had your chance and I'm going to destroy you on the internet.
Okay. So now, E, Vincent's manager, right? Yeah. He's got to fix this. He's like, what do you want? You know, he's like trying to bribe them. What happens? And he says, I want $350,000 or I'm going to destroy Aquaman online.
So, meanwhile, Johnny Drama is at Comic-Con and he has a really good friend, an adult film star, Jesse Jane, played by Jesse Jane. She's promoting her fake comic series titled F*** Patrol. So E says, hey, will you guys visit, quote, RJ in his hotel room and convince him not to write a bad review of Aquaman? And because of her love of Vincent, she's like, yeah. And her and two of her pals in very, very interesting outfits go and knock on the door and RJ is like, blah, blah, blah.
And guess what? Does Rain have a love scene with three women? I need to ask him about it. On entourage? I need to ask him about it because they go in there. They shut the door. We don't know what happens. But I wonder if there was ever a scene of anything happening.
Like, was there a scene that didn't make the episode? I don't know. But then, of course, he writes, you know, Aquaman Glowing Review. So there you go. Rain. Rain, I have questions. I have questions for you. I will be texting you later.
I really wish I knew this before Rain sent in his audio clips because I feel like the audio clips would have more, more. They would have anything to say about this. Here's when I was listening to your description of this episode, it became very clear to me why I didn't watch entourage that. And I feel good about that. I feel good that I didn't watch it. And I feel like, yeah, that good call.
Here you go, Rainn Wilson as RJ Spencer on entourage. I kind of want to see just that episode, maybe just Rainn's scenes. I just fast forwarded to Rainn's scenes. You don't really need to see anything else from it. That was some shade. And so now we can get into the episode. Jan is visiting unexpectedly and discovering Movie Monday. Yeah.
And guess what? Not everyone approves of Movie Monday, Jenna. No, Angela, you do not approve. I do not approve. It is me. I will own it. I do not approve. And then Angela is so sneaky.
When Jan comes in, she like points to the conference room like, mm-hmm, tattle tail. She is. But Angela, at one minute, 49 seconds, where are you sitting for this talking head? You're by a window and there's a plant. Oh. Where are you? I know where I am because there's a- Where?
There's a deleted scene that's not in here where Dwight has to come find me. Michael's like, go get Angela, right? And Dwight's like, why me? He plays this really coy. It's like a sort of a hilarious performance of like, well, I don't know where she is. So- Yeah. That's why are you asking me for Angela?
Yeah. And then he goes and finds her and he knows exactly where she is. I am sitting behind the vending machine sort of squished up in the wall behind the plant on a chair and I am needle pointing a fo- like a cat. I'm needle pointing a cat. And that's where this talking head is. Oh. Yes.
And there is that window that goes from the break room into that little hallway. Into the hallway. And there's a big plant there. Yeah. And that's where I'm sitting. Oh. Because there was a- It was driving me nuts.
There's a whole scene that happens there that didn't make it in the episode where I start plotting. That's the first seed I plant is that you wouldn't do this as a manager. You wouldn't waste everyone's time like this. I see. All while needle pointing a face of a cat. I love that. All right.
We have a fan catch. Angela, Beth Boss says, when Jan walks in she puts her bag and coat down on the chair in front of Michael's office. But when Angela points to the conference room and the camera cuts back to Jan, she's holding her coat and she's just now putting it down in the chair. Good catch, Beth Boss. Way to go. There's some Dwayangela sass in this episode, as we know.
And two of my favorite Dwayangela sass lines are coming up around two minutes 39. Angela is telling Dwight to meet her in the kitchen. And she says that Jan is going to be peeved off. Jan is peeved off. And then Dwight in his talking head said, yeah, Jan's really been bitching out on him ever since he broke up with her. I'm like, what is up with Dwayangela? They're like kind of cursing.
They're being a little tacky, Jenna. Oh. You think so? I think they're being a little tacky. They've hit their limit, Angela. They can't take it anymore. They can't take the inefficiency. They can't take, you know what happens?
It's like for all these years they've been separately stewing over all of this. But now that they're together. You know how that happens in a couple? Yeah. Now they're kind of like mind melding. Yeah. Well, Ange, I love this scene with Dwight and Angela in the kitchen. It's around two minutes 42 seconds.
You guys are back to back again, not facing one another. Angela is telling Dwight that he's the one who she's been writing the office and he should talk to Jan about it. We had a fan question from Evan Warburton. He says, Angela, did it make it easier or more difficult to film a scene when the characters are back to back? Because I know that Rain and Angela did quite a few scenes like this. Did it make it easier to stay in character because you didn't have to make eye contact?
What was it like? Tell us, Angela. Well, I'll tell you this. The biggest thing about these scenes that I remember was timing because you cannot see the other person speaking. So you don't respond quite the same way because you want to make sure they finish their sentence or whatever they're doing, they're emoting, whatever their thing is. So I remember the first time we did it, there were probably more pauses because we wanted
to make sure we had the give and take because naturally when you talk to someone, you're reading their face. And so it was just acting off of someone's voice as well. All of my reacting was in listening. I think in some ways it made us more thoughtful performers because we couldn't face the other person and we had to really listen to them and react off the last thing they said. Did it make it hard to improvise? Oh, for sure.
I remember really being conscious of not improvising any lines within a written scene and anything that I did improvise came at the very end when I knew I wouldn't be stepping on anything Rain said. So most of my improv in these scenes, if it made it in, was something I said as I was leaving or at the very beginning. That makes sense. So, yeah, so they have this scene in the kitchen, Angela storms out, she's furious. She tells Dwight he needs to grow a pair, right, and a talking head.
See what I mean? Jenna, she has had it. And on growing a pair, let's move to Stanford. Let's grow a pair and move to Stanford. All right, so what's happening in fancy Stanford, Jenna? They're playing Call of Duty. Jim explains that what started as a team building exercise has now turned into this super competitive game of Call of Duty, which keeps interrupting their workday.
He mentions this is where Jim brings up Pam. He's like, yeah, we didn't really play video games and Scranton, but, you know, we did other things like Pam and I would hum a high-pitched tone and try to convince Dwight that he needed to see an ear doctor. Pam called it pretendinitis. Oh, Jim, Jim, Jim, Jim, Jim, Jim. Thinking of Pam. Oh, Lordy.
But then back in Scranton, Angela, Pam is not talking about Jim. She's signing for a package. She's gotten a delivery. Listen, she went on a date last the week before, right? Yeah. Now she's getting some new clothes. With the help of Kelly Kapoor, before we really dive into this scene, you guys, four minutes, 36 seconds, is Mindy wearing a side ponytail?
Come on. You're bringing up her side ponytail. What about her bangs? I mean, she has bangs. She has bangs, but she has an extension filled side ponytail. There's a lot happening with her hair. I don't have a sting for it, but it would go full Mindy. Yeah.
Why don't we have a full Mindy sting? We really need to get on that. I don't know. Someone make this a full Mindy sting. Someone do it. Well, this leads to a very famous office line, fashion show, fashion show, fashion show at lunch. Yes.
Yes. Guys, that is 100% scripted. That was in the script. That was not an improv. It was written exactly like that. Mindy delivers it perfectly. We had a lot of fan questions about this scene. People mostly wanted to know, did I get to pick out the outfits that Pam gets in her
online shopping spree? And also, were there more things in the box besides that single shirt that she gets out and wears later in the kitchen? Okay. Yes. We had a big wardrobe fitting about what would these outfits be? And there were more things in the box, but I'll have to tell you, they were basically that same shirt, but there was a turquoise one.
It was a lot of jewel-toned shirts that looked almost identical to that one shirt that you see. And that was kind of part of the joke, because have you done that when you're shopping? You're like, I'm going to get a whole new wardrobe. And then you just kind of go to the store and buy the same pair of pants and three colors. Oh my gosh. I always do that. I find like one shirt I like and then buy it in three colors.
And people are like, hey, I, oh, have you worn that? I, is that it? And I'm like, no, it's the same shirt. It's the same shirt. Yeah. That was kind of what happened with Pam's like redesign of her wardrobe was that she managed to find one thing that she was willing to take a chance on and then bought it in different colors.
Here's what I remember about that, Jenna. Because all of us saw each other every day pretty much in the same wardrobe, right? Yeah. Whenever one of our characters did get anything slightly different, we were like, hey. So I remember our reactions to your red fancy blouse so similar to our characters minus the gross pervy stuff, but we were all like, oh my God, you look so great. Oh my God, you look amazing. And you're like, oh, it's just the wardrobe or the scene.
It did feel like that whenever we got a slightly fancier hairdo or a slightly cooler outfit. Yeah. Everyone noticed. Casting crew. We all talked about it. We were like, wow, look at that. So now we're back at Stanford, my lady. Back at Stanford.
Andy is getting ticked off at Jim for killing the wrong soldiers in Call of Duty. Yes. And did you notice that four minutes and 59 seconds, there is still a blue sticky note on Jim's computer that says smile? No, I didn't notice. That was a great catch. Yeah. It's still there.
Fan question from Shelby Hagan. How was Call of Duty chosen as the game that was played in the Stanford branch? Thank you so much for your question, Shelby. We actually got so many questions about Call of Duty, and this seemed like the perfect one to get us started. As you guys know, Jen and I were not in those scenes at Stanford. That's right. So Shelby, I reached out to a lot of people to get you the real deal on all things Call
of Duty. Angela, I got all the scoop from our line producer, Kent Sabornak. I texted with our editor, Dean Holland and Andy Bernard himself, Ed Helms. Lainey, that is a serious deep dive. I like it. I like it. I deep dived. I really did.
Okay. So what did you find out? All right. So Kent told me that after we wrapped season one of the show, the post production guys moved to some offices in Venice to edit the episodes. And while they were there, Kent just for whatever reason, just on a whim installed Call of Duty on everyone's computers, just so they could blow off steam during edit sessions. And then when we moved to our new stages for season two, he did it again, but this time
好吧。那你都发现了什么？好。肯告诉我说，在我们拍完第一季之后，后期制作团队搬到了威尼斯的一些办公室去剪辑剧集。而在那里的时候，肯不知出于什么原因，一时兴起在每个人的电脑上都安装了《使命召唤》，好让他们在剪辑间隙放松一下。接着，当我们为第二季搬到新片场时，他又照做了一遍，但这一次
he also installed it on all of the writer's computers. And that is when the editors and the writers started playing one another. I remember this because our editors and writers were in the same building. They were over where the warehouse is, right? Yeah. And the writers were upstairs and the editors were downstairs. And sometimes I would go over there at lunch because I was friends with Claire Scanlon, one of our editors at the time.
他还把它安装在了所有编剧的电脑上。也就是从那时起，剪辑师和编剧们开始互相切磋了。我记得这事，因为我们的剪辑师和编剧就在同一栋楼里。他们就在仓库那边，对吧？对。编剧在楼上，剪辑师在楼下。有时我午休时会过去，因为我和克莱尔·斯坎伦很熟，她是我们当时的一个剪辑师。
And I would walk in the editing bay and they were all like, get down over here. I was like, what is happening? I remember going up to the writer's room and seeing the same thing. They had this big conference table in the writer's room and they would have all their computers in a circle. And then some people had little offices and then some people would be around this conference room table and it was the same thing. They did exactly like what Stanford did.
然后我走进剪辑室，他们全都说：“快趴下。”我说：“发生什么事了？”我记得我走到编剧室也看到了同样的情景。编剧室里有一张很大的会议桌，他们的电脑围成一圈。然后有些人有小办公室，有些人就坐在会议桌周围，情况完全一样。他们做得跟斯坦福分部一模一样。
They would turn off the lights and they would have this elaborate match going on. Oh my gosh, they were so into it. Well I guess Greg Daniels was particularly obsessed. In fact, our editor Dean Holland told me that the very first time he met with Greg to start editing an episode, within about 10 minutes, Greg said, have you ever played Call of Duty? And Dean was like, yeah. And he said, Greg left the room and started a 20 person game, like within 10 minutes. How perfect that Greg was the person that directed this episode because he loves Call
他们会关掉灯，然后进行一场精心策划的比赛。天哪，他们太沉迷了。我想格雷格·丹尼尔斯可以说是极其着迷。事实上，我们的剪辑师迪恩·霍兰告诉我，他第一次跟格雷格见面准备剪辑一集时，大约10分钟之内，格雷格就问：“你玩过《使命召唤》吗？”迪恩说：“玩过。”然后他说，格雷格离开房间，在一转眼10分钟内就局起了一场20人的游戏。格雷格来执导这一集真是太合适了，因为他太爱《使命》
of Duty. I know. He loves it. I don't think that was a mistake. No. No. All right. Well, I have a little runner up question for you, Jenna.
《召唤》了。我知道。他太爱了。我觉得这绝不是巧合。不。不。好吧，詹娜，我有个小小的后续问题要问你。
Okay. So Evan Warburton wrote in and said, hey, I need to point this out. Jim is apparently horrible at Call of Duty at the Stanford branch in this episode. But in the episode email surveillance, you can see in the background of the scene at 20 minutes, eight seconds, that Toby is playing Call of Duty on Jim's TV. Remember at the barbecue, Jenna? Yes. Okay.
好的。埃文·沃伯顿写信来说：“嘿，我得指出这一点。在这集里，吉姆在斯坦福分部的《使命召唤》水平显然烂透了。但在《电子邮件监控》那一集里，在20分08秒的背景画面中，你可以看到托比正在吉姆的电视上玩《使命召唤》。”还记得在烧烤派对上吗，詹娜？是的。好的。
Yes. So and then also in Jim's bedroom at 15 minutes, 52 seconds, you can see an expansion pack of Call of Duty on Jim's desk. Come on, someone please explain. All right. Yes. We actually had a lot of people write in about this glitch. I went to that timecode 15 minutes, 52 seconds.
是的。所以——而且在吉姆卧室15分52秒的时候，你还可以在吉姆的书桌上看到一盘《使命召唤》的资料片。拜托，谁来解释一下。好的。是的。其实有很多观众写信来指出这个穿帮镜头。我翻到了那个时间码：15分52秒。
There it is. There is an expansion pack Call of Duty. Here's how this went down, guys. Okay. Kent told me that the writers had a card up on the wall in the writer's room all through season two about a possible Call of Duty storyline, but they couldn't really ever figure out how to put it in. And they had originally thought about doing something in email surveillance.
没错，真的有。确实有一盘《使命召唤》的资料片。事情是这样的，各位。好吧。肯告诉我，整个第二季期间，编剧们一直在编剧室的墙上贴着一张卡片，讨论一个可能涉及《使命召唤》的故事情节，但他们一直没想好怎么把它塞进剧情里。他们原本考虑在《电子邮件监控》里搞点动静。
And if you remember, Angela, we did actually shoot some scenes where people were playing Call of Duty during Jim's party. Yeah. But it wasn't a storyline. Yeah. It wasn't a storyline. It was just something people were doing at the party kind of in the background, but that was there in the script.
如果你还记得的话，安吉拉，我们在吉姆的派对上确实拍了一些大家在玩《使命召唤》的镜头。对。但它并不是一个故事情节。对。这不是一个故事情节。这只是大家在派对上作为背景随便玩玩而已，不过剧本里确实写了。
Yeah. And it didn't really though go anywhere. So finally, when they went to Stanford, they wrote this full plot line and they had to just live with the fact that there had been this tiny appearance of Call of Duty earlier, but they so wanted a full Call of Duty story that they just went with it. It was like, it's worth it. Yeah. Yeah.
对。但它其实没怎么推进剧情。所以最后，当他们去到斯坦福分部时，他们写了完整的副线剧情，只能硬着头皮接受之前《使命召唤》曾短暂出场过的事实，但他们太想要一个完整的《使命召唤》故事了，所以索性就这么拍了。他们觉得，值了。对。对。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
对。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。
Whatever, whatever email surveillance, we've got to have a real episode that features Call of Duty. You know what I did for myself, the way I made it make sense is that Jim had roommates. Yeah. He had roommates who probably played it. Maybe it was never his thing. You know? He had to put it in his mansion pack and put it in his room to make his roommate stop
管他呢，不管《电子邮件监控》怎么样，我们必须得有一集真正以《使命召唤》为主题的剧集。你知道我自己是怎么想的吗，我把它合理化了的方法是：吉姆有室友。对。他的室友可能玩这个。也许这游戏从来不是他的菜。你知道吗？他得把资料片塞进房间里，好让室友别再
playing. Maybe that's why it's in his room. All right. Along with his guitar that he never plays. Okay. Jenna and Susie. Come on. Come on.
玩了。也许这就是它为什么会在他房间里的原因。好吧。还有他那把从不弹的吉他。好吧。詹娜和苏茜。拜托。拜托。
So I listened to the DVD commentary for this episode and Jenna Rashida said that she got lessons on how to play Call of Duty from the writers. As soon as she got the job, they started teaching her how to play Call of Duty, which cracks me up. And John actually had something really sweet to say in the commentary. He said that going to the Stanford branch, all of those actors had never worked together before, right? And that playing Call of Duty with one another was actually a really fun icebreaker to get
我听了这集的DVD评论音轨，詹娜·拉什达说她是从编剧那里学怎么玩《使命召唤》的。她一得到这份工作，他们就开始教她怎么玩《使命召唤》，这把我逗乐了。而且约翰在评论音轨里也说了一段非常暖心的话。他说，去到斯坦福分部时，那些演员以前从来没有一起合作过，对吧？大家一起玩《使命召唤》其实是一个非常有趣的破冰方式，能让大家
to know everyone. You know, Ed and I traded some messages and he said the same thing. He said they all played with the writers and it was really, really fun. And he told me that they also played for real on set. Yeah. They were really playing during those scenes. And then when they would cut, they would just keep playing. He said it was a lot of fun and people got super, super into it.
互相了解。埃德和我互发过信息，他也这么说。他说他们都和编剧一起玩，真的非常非常有趣。而且他告诉我，他们在片场也是来真的。对。他们在那些镜头里是真玩。然后导演喊卡的时候，他们就继续玩。他说这特别有意思，大家都超级超级投入。
I have a little FOMO. I have a little FOMO about it because I feel like we would have had fun with that at Scranton. I mean, all we... See, we knew they were having fun over there without us. We knew us. Dang it. All we were doing was playing Solitaire. Exactly.
我有点嫉妒。我对此有点“错失恐惧症”，因为我觉得我们在斯克兰顿也会玩得很开心的。我是说，我们所有……看吧，我们知道他们在另一边玩得很开心，而我们却被蒙在鼓里。我们太清楚了。该死。我们当时只会玩纸牌接龙。没错。
Oh, Jenna, did you get any scoop in your deep dive on who was the best player? Who was our best player? Well, I don't think any of the actors were very good. Oh, really? Ed said he didn't remember anyone being particularly great, including himself. Kent told me that he was the best player when they started, but that during the editing phase of season one, when they were in Venice, co-producer Angie Hamilton was the best. Wow.
哦，詹娜，你在深挖时有没有打听到谁是玩得最好的那个？谁是我们这里玩得最好的？嗯，我觉得没哪个演员技术很好。哦，真的吗？埃德说他不记得有谁特别厉害，包括他自己。肯告诉我，一开始他是玩得最好的，但在第一季剪辑阶段他们在威尼斯的时候，联合制片人安吉·汉密尔顿才是最厉害的。哇。
But then, see, it sort of depends on who you ask because Dean told me that during season two, he and writer Mike Scher were the best. They were at the top of the leaderboard. He said they got so into it that they took it over to Parks and Rec when they moved over there and they played it every day on Parks and Rec. And Kent did concur that Mike and Dean left as champions, but he also said that their assistant editor, Mike Zurer, was pretty great. All right.
但后来，这得看你问谁了，因为迪恩告诉我，在第二季期间，他和编剧迈克·舒尔是玩得最好的。他们高居排行榜榜首。他说他们太沉迷了，以至于后来他们转去拍《公园与游憩》时把这游戏也带过去了，每天在《公园与游憩》剧组都在玩。肯也确实承认迈克和迪恩最后是作为冠军离开的，但他还说他们的助理剪辑师迈克·祖雷尔也很厉害。好吧。
All right. Well, I think those were fantastic questions. Thank you so much, Shelby and Evan. All right. So now, at five minutes, 12 seconds, we're in the parking lot, Dwight, you know, he's kind of psyching himself up. Like he does that. We've seen him do this before, like in the stairwell.
好吧，我觉得这些问题太棒了。非常感谢谢尔比和埃文。好的，那么现在，在5分12秒时，我们来到了停车场，德怀特，你知道的，他正在给自己打气。就像他平时那样。我们以前见过他这样，比如在楼梯间里。
And in the DVD commentary, Rain mentioned that that run that he does in the parking lot that Paul Lieberstein showed him exactly how he wanted that run done. Really? I picture these two guys just running back and forth. It makes me laugh thinking about it. And then Dwight calls Jan and he says, hey, I need to talk to you. It's not safe here. He's crouching down.
而在DVD评论音轨中，雷恩提到他在停车场里的那段跑姿，是保罗·利伯斯坦精确示范给他看的，告诉他想要什么样的跑效。真的吗？我脑海中浮现出这两个人跑来跑去的画面。一想到这我就觉得好笑。然后德怀特打电话给简，他说：“嘿，我得跟你谈谈。这里不安全。”他蹲了下来。
People are walking about. Kevin's around and he tells her to go to the Liz Claiborne outlet at Exit 40 because he knows that she likes buying those blouses from Liz Claiborne. Yeah. He says he'll meet her there. Yeah. I'll meet you at the Liz Claiborne outlet. He says, go in and shop.
周围有人走来走去。凯文也在附近，他叫简去40号出口的丽资·克莱本奥特莱斯，因为他知道她喜欢买丽资·克莱本的衬衫。对。他说他会在那儿跟她碰头。对。我在丽资·克莱本奥特莱斯等你。他说：“进去逛逛吧。
I'll meet you there. And she says, how do you know I like their blouses? And he says, it's part of my job to know. And then she has that great line where she's like, it literally is not part of your job. Yeah. It's absolutely not part of your job to know this. And then Dwight's like, noted, how long has Dwight been tracking her clothes? I feel like Dwight is the tracker, the way we track things on the podcast.
我在那儿等你。”然后简说：“你怎么知道我喜欢他们的衬衫？”他说：“了解这些是我的工作职责的一部分。”接着简说了一句绝妙的话：“这绝对不是你的工作职责。”对。了解这些绝对不是你的工作职责。然后德怀特说：“记下了。”德怀特跟踪她的衣服多久了？我觉得德怀特就是那个“跟踪狂”，就像我们在播客里追踪各种细节一样。
That's what Dwight was doing of like everyone in the office. He's got some real creepy notebooks. Oh, he has meticulous creepy notes. Lady, I had to do a deep dive the minute he said Exit 40. I had to know, are there Liz Claiborne outlets at Exit 40? So I can tell you all the outlets in Pennsylvania. Did you go there, lady? Did you go there?
德怀特对办公室里的每个人就是这么干的。他有一些真正的毛骨悚然的笔记本。哦，他有极其细致、让人毛骨悚然的笔记。天哪，他一说40号出口，我马上就去深挖了。我必须知道，40号出口真的有丽资·克莱本奥特莱斯吗？这样我就能向大家介绍宾夕法尼亚州所有的奥特莱斯了。你去了吗，天哪？你去了吗？
Okay. I did not go there, Angela, because remember when I said earlier that our fans got real into some deep dives on this? We had multiple people write in about Liz Claiborne outlets and Exit 40. Jenny Aguirre wrote in to say, there is no Exit 40 according to three Google map suggestions from Scranton to New York. Did you find that, Angela? No Exit 40?
好吧，我没去，安吉拉，因为还记得我刚才说过我们的粉丝对各种细节深挖得很彻底吗？有多个人写信跟我们聊了丽资·克莱本奥特莱斯和40号出口的事。珍妮·阿吉雷写信说：“根据从斯克兰顿到纽约的三条谷歌地图路线，根本没有40号出口。”你找到了吗，安吉拉？没有40号出口吗？
Yeah. I couldn't find an Exit 40 either. Okay, well, McKayla Brock said that the only Liz Claiborne store near Scranton is in Ramsey, New Jersey, which is about an hour and 45 minutes away on the quickest route. But Elizabeth M said that Jan has said she's been driving an hour supposedly to New York City, which would not be on the way to this Liz Claiborne outlet that is in New Jersey, and it would actually add 25 miles to her drive. Well, I want you to know when I was in junior high, my favorite perfume was the Liz Claiborne
对。我也没找到40号出口。好吧，麦凯拉·布洛克说，斯克兰顿附近唯一的丽资·克莱本商店在新泽西州的拉姆齐，如果走最快路线，单程大约要一个小时四十五分钟。但伊丽莎白·M说，简曾说过她据说要开一个小时的车去纽约市，这根本不在去这家位于新泽西的丽资·克莱本奥特莱斯的路上，而且实际上会让她的车程多出25英里。好吧，我想让你们知道，我上初中时，我最喜欢的香水就是丽资·克莱本
perfume. Oh! It came in a little like triangle, you know, and you took the top off. I loved Liz Claiborne perfume. So I would have been very excited about this Liz Claiborne outlets. And my mom loves the outlets. We had to pull off on the side of the road like she would say to my dad, Bill, there's the outlets.
香水。哦！它装在一个小三角形的瓶子里，你知道的，把盖子拔掉就行。我太喜欢丽资·克莱本香水了。所以我对这些丽资·克莱本奥特莱斯肯定会超级兴奋。而且我妈妈超爱奥特莱斯。我们以前在路上开车时，她会突然对爸爸说：“比尔，看呐，有奥特莱斯。”
Here we go. Oh! My mom loves the outlets, there is a Carter's outlet, there's a baby gap outlet. My mom shops the outlet and she sends just like bags of clothes to me for my kids from these outlets. It's the best. Guys, loving on the outlets. So you can go to outletlocator.com and type in your state and find out your outlets.
我们到了。哦！我妈妈超爱奥特莱斯，那里有卡特童装奥特莱斯，有婴儿盖普奥特莱斯。我妈妈在奥特莱斯疯狂购物，然后从这些奥特莱斯买一大袋一大袋的衣服寄给我的孩子们。太棒了。各位，对奥特莱斯是真爱。所以你可以去outletlocator.com输入你的州，就能找到你的奥特莱斯。
So this is what I found. There are three outlets in Pennsylvania for Liz Claiborne. There's one in Lancaster, one in Hershey, and one in Reading. And then, lady, when we get to it later, I'll let you know what outletlocator.com says about Ann Taylor. I'll hold on to that. I'll hold on to it. Oh, yes.
这就是我查到的。宾夕法尼亚州有三家丽资·克莱本奥特莱斯。兰开斯特有一家，好时有一家，雷丁有一家。然后，天哪，等我们待会儿聊到时，我会告诉你outletlocator.com上关于安·泰勒的信息。我先保留这个。我先卖个关子。哦，是的。
Many people wrote in about Ann Taylor. So we'll put a pin in that. So and then, you know, Dwight gets off the phone and he tells Michael he has an emergency crown that he has to get put in. Michael's like, oh, that, you know, that sucks. And he said, yeah, it's a new dentist that is three hours away. And off Dwight goes. Well, Michaela Brock wants you to know that if Dwight goes to a Liz Claiborne store in
很多人写信提到安·泰勒。所以我们先暂且搁置。然后，你知道的，德怀特挂了电话，告诉迈克他有个紧急的牙冠要去做。迈克说：“哦，那，真够糟糕的。”德怀特说：“对，是一家三小时车程外的牙医诊所。”然后德怀特就出发了。好吧，麦凯拉·布洛克想让你知道，如果德怀特去了新泽西州的丽资·克莱本商店，他离开的时间绝对会超过三小时，因为光是单程开车时间就要三小时。他甚至根本没时间跟简见面。
New Jersey, he would have been gone longer than three hours because driving time alone would have been three hours. He wouldn't have even had time to meet with Jan. Guys, we did not think this through. Our writers did not go to outletlocator.com when they wrote this scene. They did not. Well, at wherever he went, Dwight is now in a parking lot with Jan. And she has done some shopping.
各位，我们没把这逻辑盘顺。我们的编剧在写这场戏时根本没有上outletlocator.com查过。他们压根没查。好吧，不管他去了哪里，德怀特现在正和一个停车场里的简碰面。而且她已经战利品满载了。她提着好多袋子。她提着好多袋子。
She's got some bags. She's got some bags. I have a question for you, Janice, since I know you have the scripts. There is this line that Dwight says to Jan, and I feel like it's rain improving when he said, did you get a new blouse, halter top, camisole, Teddy? Is that rain improvising? All of that was scripted except for Teddy. Teddy.
我有问题要问你，詹娜，既然我知道你有剧本。德怀特对简说了一句台词，我觉得那是雷恩的即兴发挥，他说：“你买了一件新衬衫、挂脖上衣、吊带衫、性感内衣吗？”那是雷恩的即兴发挥吗？除了性感内衣外，所有的台词都是剧本里写好的。性感内衣。
There you go. I knew one of them. He threw in Teddy at the end. I knew one of them had to be rain. You would be friends with Kate Launergen who wrote in that same question, lady. Oh, hi, Kate. All right. Dwight and Jan have a meeting at a nearby restaurant, and this is where Dwight really
你看吧。我猜对了一个。他最后临时加了“性感内衣”。我就知道其中有一个是雷恩自己加的。你一定会和凯特·劳纳根成为朋友，她写信问的就是同一个问题，天哪。哦，嗨，凯特。好吧。德怀特和简在附近的一家餐馆见面，正是在这里，德怀特彻底
turns on Michael, and he starts to campaign to take over the office. He campaigns and grosses me out at the same time. I mean, I am impressed with his no-look poor, and no-look poor of syrup is no joke. Lady, that was scripted. I mean, that was amazing. I thought the same thing. I looked it up in the script, and there is a stage direction that says, here's what it says, Dwight takes the syrup as he talks without breaking eye contact with Jan and
向迈克反水了，他开始游说自己来接管办公室。他一边游说一边让我起鸡皮疙瘩。我是说，我对他的“盲倒糖浆”印象深刻，不看瓶子直接往盘子里倒糖浆可真不是盖的。天哪，那可是剧本里写好的。我是说，太神了。我也这么觉得。我在剧本里查过了，上面有舞台说明，它是这么写的：德怀特一边说话一边拿过糖浆，视线自始至终没有离开过简，
pours it over everything on his plate. Amazing. Amazing. We did get some questions, lady, about his eating of the waffles and pancakes, which is also delightful. That was not scripted. Rain just ate how he wanted to eat. Casey helped and asked, how much of those waffles and pancakes did Rain have to eat
直接把它倒在他盘子里的所有食物上。太绝了。太绝了。天哪，我们确实收到了一些关于他吃华夫饼和煎饼的问题，那一段也十分搞笑。那可不是剧本里写的。雷恩想怎么吃就怎么吃。凯西·海尔普问：在那个场景里，雷恩到底吃了多少华夫饼和煎饼？
in that scene? Was he really eating them, or did he have a spit bucket? Well, guess what? Rain Wilson answers this eating question. All right. Let's play the clip, Sam. Here's what Rain has to say. Here's my deal about eating scenes.
他是真的吃下去了，还是准备了吐口水桶？好吧，你猜怎么着？雷恩·威尔逊亲自回答了这个关于吃的问题。好吧。放片断吧，萨姆。听听雷恩是怎么说的。关于吃戏，我的原则是这样的。
I love to eat during eating scenes. I love, and if you'll see Dwight, he'll always, when there's an eating scene, he's got a mouth full of food. To me, it's really funny. He's just wolfing down big bites of food and talking while eating, and it's disgusting, but it just felt really, really right for the character, and I also like it as an actor. This was a joy to cover, and I love that stage direction of Dwight's eyes never leave jams as he covers his plate entirely in syrup, and Melora Hardin is such a joy to act with
我很喜欢在吃戏里吃东西。我喜欢，如果你看德怀特的戏，每当有吃东西的场景时，他嘴里总是塞满食物。对我来说，这真的太搞笑了。他就是大口大口地吞咽食物，一边吃一边说话，虽然这很恶心，但对这个角色来说感觉真的太对了，而且作为演员我也很喜欢这种感觉。拍这场戏是一种享受，我太喜欢那个舞台说明了：德怀特的眼睛始终没有离开过简，同时把糖浆完全浇满整个盘子。而且和梅洛拉·哈丁演对手戏简直是一种享受，
because she's so specific and so underplayed, and no matter what you throw at her, she's right there. She's totally game and always in character. All right. So there you have it, guys. Rain was really eating. He was really eating, not spitting them out. Rain did not use a spit bucket.
因为她太细腻、太克制了，不管你抛给她什么梗，她都能稳稳接住。她完全放得开，随时都处于角色状态中。好了。所以你们看，各位。雷恩是真的在吃。他是真的在吃，而不是吐出来。雷恩没有用吐口水桶。
I have done a lot of scenes with Rain Wilson, and I can tell you, the guy goes for it. He goes for it across the board, whatever it is. So if he was going to eat a waffle by Golly, he's going to eat that waffle. Well, thank you, Rain. Thank you for sitting in that clip. We've got more guys coming up. This is also the scene, lady, where at the end of the scene, he tells Jan there's an Anne Taylor store nearby, and he knows that she likes the earrings.
我和雷恩·威尔逊拍过很多对手戏，我能告诉你的是，这家伙演戏是来真的。不管是什么戏，他都是全力以赴。所以既然他决定要吃华夫饼，天哪，他就会把那块华夫饼吃干抹净。好吧，谢谢你，雷恩。谢谢你发来的这段视听片段。我们后面还有更多精彩内容，各位。这也是那个场景，天哪，在那个场景的结尾，他告诉简附近有一家安·泰勒商店，而且他知道她喜欢那里的耳环。
Melora's performance as Jan is so great. She's like, where is it? Yeah, she's like, yeah, where is it? I do actually. I do want to look at the earrings. Well, Michaela Brock wants you to know that while there are 20 Anne Taylor stores around the Scranton area, the nearest one to a Liz Claiborne is about 16 minutes away. Now Jenny added, Angela, I told you, everyone deep dived on this.
梅洛拉对简的演绎简直太棒了。她一副“在哪儿？”的表情。对，她就像是，“对，在哪儿？”我确实挺想的。我真的很想去看看耳环。好吧，麦凯拉·布洛克想让你知道，虽然斯克兰顿周边有20家安·泰勒商店，但离丽资·克莱本最近的一家也要大约16分钟车程。现在珍妮补充道：“安吉拉，我早就说过，每个人都把这些细节深挖到底了。”
There is an outlet mall roughly an hour away from Scranton. I think this is the one you're talking about. It's on the I-80 East route. It's called the Crossings Premium Outlet. Did you find this one? Well, I can tell you on outletlocator.com, there is an Anne Taylor outlet in Lancaster as well, and also one in Hershey as well. So if you were at Liz Claiborne, you could hit Anne Taylor at both of those outlets.
距离斯克兰顿大约一个小时车程的地方有一个奥特莱斯购物中心。我想这就是你刚才说的那个。它在80号州际公路东线。名字叫“十字路口奥特莱斯”（Crossings Premium Outlet）。你找到这个了吗？好吧，我可以告诉你，在outletlocator.com上，兰开斯特也有一家安·泰勒奥特莱斯，好时也有一家。所以如果你在丽资·克莱本，你可以在那两处奥特莱斯顺便逛逛安·泰勒。
And then there's another one in Tannersville and Pottstown. But there's no Liz Claiborne at those. No, but you have a Liz Claiborne crossover at Hershey and Lancaster. Well, Jenny was noting that at the Crossings Premium Outlet, there is also Billy's Pocono Diner. So they serve breakfast, and it is possible that that's where they were eating. And then Jan could pop over to that Anne Taylor. According to Kentopedia, however, for anyone who wants to know, this was shot in Tlucalate,
然后坦纳斯威尔和波茨坦还有另外两家。但那些地方没有丽资·克莱本。对，不过你在好时和兰开斯特可以两家都逛到。好吧，珍妮指出，在十字路口奥特莱斯，还有一家比利波科诺餐厅。所以他们供应早餐，他们当时可能就是在那儿吃饭。然后简就可以顺便去那家安·泰勒。不过根据肯百科全书的说法，对于想知道的人，这一场其实是在加利福尼亚州
California at Patty Steiner, famous Patty Steiner. All right. I've eaten there. And so I can tell you with great authority that Rainn Wilson was eating delicious pancakes and waffles at Patty's. All right. Well, we've got to get back to the Scranton branch because the shiitake is about to hit the fan.
图卢卡湖的帕蒂·施泰纳餐馆拍摄的，大名鼎鼎的帕蒂·施泰纳餐馆。好吧。我在那里吃过。所以我可以极其权威地告诉你，雷恩·威尔逊当时在帕蒂餐馆吃的确实是美味的煎饼和华夫饼。好吧，好了，我们得回斯克兰顿分部了，因为好戏就要上演了。
Yeah. But before we do that, let's take a little break. Yeah, let's take a break. I'm going to refill my coffee. You refill your coffee. Is that cool? I'm probably going to go pee. Overshare?
对。但在那之前，我们先休息一小会儿。对，我们休息一会儿。我去续杯咖啡。你去续杯咖啡。可以吗？我大概要顺便去上个厕所。分享过头了？
Maybe. That's where I'm at. You always pee during our breaks. It's kind of like, remember when you gave me grief about saying, do you want to hear a summary? Do you want to hear a fast fact when you know I'm going to say them anyway? It's kind of like, you don't have to tell us that you're going to pee on the breaks anymore because we all just know.
也许吧。我目前就是这状态。你每次休息都要上厕所。这有点像，还记得你以前怪我说：“你想听个剧情梗概吗？你想听个速记冷知识吗？”明明你知道我无论如何都会说。这有点像，你不用再告诉我们你在休息时要去上厕所了，因为我们大家心里都有数。
Listen. We just know. Okay, fine. You have a tiny bladder. I have a tiny bladder. I'm a tiny person. I do as well. Listen.
听着。我们就是知道。好吧，好吧。你膀胱很小。我膀胱很小。我是个娇小的人。我也一样。听着。
I pee on every break too. I just haven't been talking about it. Well, I am hell on a road trip. If we can have a road trip again, you don't want me in the car with you because I need to know where I can pee. I'm that person. Where am I going to pee? Yeah.
我每次休息也都要上厕所。我只是没说出来而已。好吧，我要是去公路旅行简直就是个灾难。如果我们以后还能一起公路旅行，你绝对不想让我坐你的车，因为我必须随时知道哪里能上厕所。我就是那种人。我上哪儿上厕所去呀？对。
Where am I going to pee? Where am I going to pee? Get me an iced tea. Where am I going to pee? I know. I drink my way through a road trip just sodas and water and snacks and then also pee seven times. Maybe we are perfect partners for road tripping because we would just know we're going to
我上哪儿上厕所去呀？我上哪儿上厕所去呀？给我来杯冰茶。我上哪儿上厕所去呀？我知道。我在公路旅行中一路狂喝苏打水、水和零食，然后还要上七次厕所。也许我们俩是公路旅行的绝配，因为我们俩都会知道我们要
pee and we're going to- Yeah, but we'd have to sync up. We would need someone to be the alpha bladder and someone to be the beta bladder. Now you do sound like Dwight. All right. Let's take a break. All right. We're back.
上厕所，并且我们要——对，但我们得同步一下。我们需要一个人当“主膀胱”，一个人当“副膀胱”。你现在听起来越来越像德怀特了。好吧。我们休息一下。好吧。我们回来了。
Jan has called Michael to tell him he needs to get a hold of his employees. And do a better job because they are going behind his back to her. Right? Yes. And Michael cannot believe that Dwight would try to turn his ex-lover-ish against him. One of my favorite lines, and it's probably because of how earnestly Steve says it as Michael, is when Jan calls him and he says, you were at the dentist. Oh, yes.
简给迈克打电话，告诉他必须管好自己的员工。把工作做好，因为他们背着他直接去找她了。对吧？是的。而且迈克简直不敢相信德怀特竟然会试图策反他曾经的“准地下情人”来对付他。我最喜欢的台词之一，可能完全是因为史蒂夫把迈克的那种真挚感演出来了，就是当简打电话给他时，他说：“你当时在牙医那里。”哦，是的。
Michael thinks that she randomly ran into Dwight where he was getting his crown removed. And they were like, no, Michael, it's all a lie. Yes. Oh, yes. I love it so much. Well, Angela, then we move into the kitchen where Pam is modeling her new top for Kelly and Phyllis. This is the fashion show.
迈克以为她是在德怀特拔牙的地方偶遇了德怀特。他们心想：“不，迈克，全都是谎言。”是的。哦，太棒了。好吧，安吉拉，然后我们来到了厨房，帕姆正在为凯利和菲利斯展示她的新上衣。这就是一场时装秀。
And then Roy walks in with a soda and he is, oh, Pam's like taking his breath away right here. Poor Roy. Is there not a vending machine in the warehouse? Come on. In that whole warehouse, there's not a vending machine. You've got to come up to the office three times for a soda. Well, you know what?
接着罗伊拿着一罐苏打水走了进来，他整个人——哦，帕姆在这里简直快让他窒息了。可怜的罗伊。仓库里难道没有自动售货机吗？拜诺。整间仓库里连个自动售货机都没有。你得为了喝罐苏打水跑回办公室三次。好吧，你知道吗？
That line was improved by Mindy. Oh, way to go, Mindy. Isn't that so good? Yes, she had that same thought, right? Like, oh, third soda of the day. In the script, as he's walking out the kitchen door, she was just supposed to say, awkward. Oh, nice. All right, so when we go back to Stanford, Josh puts the game on hold.
那句台词是明迪即兴发挥的。哦，干得漂亮，明迪。是不是太棒了？是的，她当时也是这么想的，对吧？就像是，“哦，今天的第三罐苏打水。”在剧本里，当他走出厨房门时，她本来只需说一句：“真尴尬。”哦，不错。好吧，镜头切回斯坦福分部，乔希把游戏暂停了。
He calls Andy and Jim into the conference room. Jim is like, oh, finally we're doing work. No, no. He wants to devise a strategy for the game. So speaking of improvisation, Ed had a bunch of improv at the end of the scene. So when he calls Jim a saboteur, that was improvised, that was not in the script. And then when he says all that stuff where he's like, I am going to kill you for real. This game is over.
他把安迪和吉姆叫进了会议室。吉姆心想：“哦，谢天谢地，我们终于要干正事了。”不，不。他是想为游戏制定一个策略。说起即兴发挥，埃德在那场戏的结尾有一大串即兴台词。所以当他叫吉姆为“蓄意破坏者”时，那是他即兴发挥的，剧本里根本没有。然后当他说那些话，比如“我真的要杀了你。游戏结束了。
I am really going to shoot you. Like all of that, that was Ed improv. Well, in the DVD commentary, John said that this scene was maybe one of the hardest that he had to work not to break. He said that Chip and Ed, Chip who plays Josh, were just crushing it. And he said he was having the toughest time. So I kind of want to rewatch it to watch his face. But lady, I have a little trivia about Rain and Chip, Chip who plays Josh.
我真的要开枪打死你”——所有这些，全都是埃德的即兴发挥。好吧，在DVD评论音轨中，约翰说这场戏可能是他演得最艰难的一场，为了不笑场简直拼尽全力。他说饰演出乔希的奇普和埃德简直演技炸裂。他说他当时难受极了。所以我有点想重温一下这一段，好好观察他的表情。不过，天哪，我这里有一个关于雷恩和奇普的小八卦，饰演乔希的奇普。
Oh, what is it? OK, so did you know that Rain and Chip were in an NBC pilot in 1999? It was called The Expendables. Now Rain mentioned this in the DVD commentary, and I had to do a deep dive. I was like, what? It sounds like a superhero fantasy type show. Ready? I looked it up online.
哦，是什么？好吧，你知道雷恩和奇普在1999年曾一起出演过一部NBC的试播集吗？名字叫《消耗品》（The Expendables）。雷恩在DVD评论音轨里提到过这事，我当时不得不去深挖了一下。我想：什么？听起来像是某种超级英雄奇幻剧。准备好了吗？我在网上查了一下。
This is what IMDb had to say about it. The Expendables was an NBC pilot. It was about a scientist who creates two indestructible, lifelike robots. They have an affinity for television, particularly Starsky and Hutch. Their unexpected development of emotions prompts a need for them to help people. Chuck played the character Ram, Rain played the character Newman. Now are those characters both the robots who developed feelings? The robots.
IMDb上是这么介绍它的：《消耗品》是一部NBC的试播集。讲的是一个科学家创造了两个刀枪不入、栩栩如生的机器人。它们对电视节目情有独钟，尤其是《警界双雄》。它们意外萌生的情感促使它们去帮助人类。奇普饰演的角色叫拉姆，雷恩饰演的角色叫纽曼。这两个角色难道都是萌生了情感的机器人吗？机器人。
OK. Yeah, and Rain said it was so bad, but that he and Chip became friends, and Rain was one of the people that suggested Chip for the role of Josh. That is some good. I would call that a tidbit and a deep dive. That's a deep tidbit. Can we go to Scranton now? We probably should.
哦。对，雷恩说这部剧烂透了，但他和奇普因此成为了朋友，而且雷恩还是向剧组推荐奇普出演乔希这个角色的幕后推手之一。这料可真够猛的。我觉得这既是个幕后趣闻，也是个深度八卦。这料藏得可真深。我们现在能回斯克兰顿了吗？我们大概是该回去了。
This is one of my favorite all time scenes of all time on any television show ever made ever. This is one of my favorite bits ever. Crentist the dentist. Your dentist's name is Crentist. Maybe that's why he became a dentist. There is a deleted scene. There is a deleted scene where Michael Scott, Michael, he's like Scott, and he starts seeing
这是我这辈子看过的所有电视剧里最喜欢的场景之一，有史以来最喜欢的。这是我最喜欢的桥段之一。牙医克伦蒂斯（Crentist）。你的牙医叫克伦蒂斯。也许这就是他为什么去当牙医的原因。有一个被删减的片段。有一个被删减的片段是迈克尔·斯科特，迈克尔，他就像是斯科特，他开始盘算
what all would name with Scott, but he said none of them are occupations. OK, so in the script, the Crentist dentist scene is word for word, you guys. There is nothing improvised about this scene. This was all written by Paul Lieberstein. Paul, you are a genius. It is perfection. And you're right. There's a deleted talking head, and then there is even more to this scene in the script
所有跟“斯科特”沾边的名字，但他发现没有一个是职业。好吧，在剧本里，“牙医克伦蒂斯”这场戏可是逐字逐句一字不差的，各位。这场戏没有任何即兴发挥。全都是保罗·利伯斯坦写的。保罗，你真是个天才。这简直完美。而且你说得对。这里有一个被删减的单人访谈，剧本里其实还有更多关于这场戏的内容
that is deleted. So if you want to see like an extended version of this genius, please visit the deleted scenes. I love it so much. We asked Rain about it and he sent in this clip. All righty then, Office Ladies podcast, Jenna, Angela, hi, it's me, Rainn Wilson. Remember me? Vaguely. Everyone talks about the Crentist scene as being so spectacular and I know that it's
全都被删掉了。所以如果你想看这个天才设定的加长版，请去看删减片段。我太爱了。我们问了雷恩关于这场戏的看法，他发来了这段视频。那么好吧，办公室女士播客，詹娜，安吉拉，嗨，我是雷恩·威尔逊。还记得我吗？隐约记得。每个人都说克伦蒂斯这场戏精彩绝伦，我知道这是
some of the funniest writing. I think Paul Lieberstein wrote it in all of the Office, the dentist, Crentist, and that jousting between me and Michael, but the scene afterwards where Dwight and Michael play this chess game and Michael pretends to give up his position to Dwight is absolutely masterful. And I think Steve is, I mean, he's great in everything, but he just kills it. And it's so subtle and underplayed. And I love how Game of Thrones it is. I forgot that this whole episode is like these power plays and power ploys and who's going
《办公室》里最好笑的剧本之一，保罗·利伯斯坦写的牙医、克伦蒂斯，还有我和迈克之间的那场唇枪舌剑。但随后的那场戏——德怀特和迈克下国际象棋，迈克假装把职位让给德怀特——简直是神来之笔。而且我觉得史蒂夫——我是说，他演什么都棒，但在这一场里他简直封神了。既微妙又克制。我太喜欢它那种《权力的游戏》的感觉了。我差点忘了整集都在上演这种权力博弈、权谋诡计，看看到底是谁在谁的
behind who's back. It's like little finger and Valeris in Highgarden or whatever. I think I'm getting all the Game of Thrones names wrong. But in the Red Keep, all the maneuvering, you know, the Lannisters and backstabbing and loyalty and you don't know whose side who's on. And it's so fantastic. But the thing that gets me every time is that the reason it all falls apart is that Dwight insults the sea brain.
背后捅刀子。这就像是高庭的“小指头”和瓦里斯，或者别的什么。我觉得我把《权力的游戏》里的名字全搞混了。但在红堡里，所有的纵横捭阖，你知道的，兰尼斯家族的尔虞我诈、背叛和忠诚，让你根本分不清谁是谁的人。这太精彩了。但每次最让我绝育的是，这一切之所以分崩离析，原因竟然是德怀特侮辱了海马脑。
And ultimately, the sea brain is the hinge is the lynch pin, and it all falls apart because of the sea brain. But this episode was so well written, I remember there's sometimes when you just are like, it's just best to sit back and play the lines and have fun with them as much as possible. And I think this was one of those and I often felt that way about Paul Lieberstein's writing. It's very specific and it was made worse through improvisation, not better. Sometimes the writing could benefit from some kind of actors bringing their mojo. But it was not that way with the coup.
归根结底，海马脑才是那个关键环节，是整个局的枢纽，而一切崩塌全都是因为海马脑。但这一集写得实在是太好了，我记得有时候你会觉得，最好还是静静坐着，把台词念好，尽可能从中找乐子。我觉得这就是那种剧本，我常常对保罗·利伯斯坦的剧本有这种感觉。它非常具体，靠演员临场发挥反而会把事情搞砸，而不是变得更好。有时候剧本确实能从演员注入的个人魅力中受益。但“政变”这一集可不是这样的。
There you have it. You know, I was screaming back at him even though he couldn't hear me because it was recorded audio clip. I love that you brought up Littlefinger and Cersei. Because Reign, I love Game of Thrones too, and I am Cersei. Angela is Cersei. In this episode, she's Cersei. All right.
你们听到了吧。你知道吗，我在屏幕那边冲他大喊大叫，尽管他根本听不见，因为这只是一段录好的音频片段。我太喜欢你提到小指头和瑟曦了。因为雷恩，我也超爱《权力的游戏》，而我就是瑟曦。安吉拉是瑟曦。在这一集里，她就是瑟曦。好吧。
Well, Reign brought up the scene where they're in Michael's office and Michael turns the tables on Dwight and it all falls apart. And I have to agree in rewatching this, Crentist is so funny, but this dance between Steve and Reign and how they perform this scene, I think Reign is right. This is just like amazing acting and performance in writing that scene. It's all genius. It is all amazing. I watched this episode three times and I could watch it again just for that scene.
好吧，雷恩提到了他们在迈克尔办公室里的那场戏，迈克尔反将了德怀特一军，一切瞬间土崩瓦解。我不得不赞同，重温这一段时，克伦蒂斯固然好笑，但史蒂夫和雷恩之间的这场拉锯战以及他们的表演，我觉得雷恩说得对。这简直就是顶级的演技与表演，还有无敌的剧本。全都是天才之作。简直太神了。我看这一集看了三遍，为了这场戏我甚至愿意再刷一遍。
It is so good. And one of the things they talked about in the DVD commentary, and I actually remember this, is Greg really wanted to live in the pauses. He wasn't afraid at all to let them take their time because he wanted it to have that kind of weight to it. And it just played so beautifully. We had a lot of questions about improvisation, I think because these scenes are so well-performed. People think that they were improvised.
真的太棒了。他们在DVD评论音轨里谈论的事情之一，而且我确实还记得，就是格雷格非常想留出足够的停顿空间。他一点也不怕让他们慢慢来，因为他希望整场戏能有一种沉甸甸的分量感。呈现出来的效果实在太美妙了。我们收到了很多关于即兴发挥的问题，我想大概是因为这些戏的表演太出色了，大家以为是即兴演出来的。
So we had Carolyn Tuft wrote in about Michael's talking head, where he's talking about businesses like a jungle and he's the tiger. She wanted to know if Steve improvised any of that, nope, all scripted. Jerry Shoe wrote in to say, around 14 minutes, 40 seconds, Dwight calls Michael Mike as they're getting ready to go out to the bullpen. And he said, I think this is the only time that Dwight ever called Michael Mike in the entire show, would you happen to know why? That was scripted.
所以卡洛琳·塔夫特写信问了迈克尔关于商业就像丛林、他是老虎的那段单人访谈。她想知道史蒂夫是不是即兴发挥的，不，全都是剧本写的。杰里·舒写信说，在14分40秒左右，德怀特和迈克准备去大办公室时，德怀特叫了迈克尔一声“迈克”（Mike）。他说，我觉得这是整部剧中德怀特唯一一次叫迈克尔为“迈克”，你知道这是为什么吗？那是剧本写的。
And it's scripted because Dwight thinks he has all the power now. So he is calling him Mike as a way to kind of demote him. Oh yeah, no, he's doing that thing where you give people nicknames to sort of put them in their place. And it is so brilliant because, you know, he's also taking the power away. And Michael's like, should we go out there and he goes, when I'm ready, Mike? Yeah, it's brilliant. Well, when Michael does break the news to everyone, oh, Angela, you are so pleased.
剧本之所以这么写，是因为德怀特觉得自己现在大权在握了。所以他叫他“迈克”其实是一种贬低他的方式。哦，对，不，他就是在用那种给别人起绰号的方式来把对方压制在应有的位置上。这实在是太高明了，因为，你知道的，他同时也在剥夺迈克尔的权力。迈克尔问：“我们要出去吗？”他回答：“等我准备好了，迈克？”对，太绝了。好吧，当迈克尔终于把这个消息宣布给大家时，哦，安吉拉，你简直开心极了。
So pleased. Stanley has a lot of questions. Phyllis asked Michael what he plans to do. And Kevin is very concerned that Michael's going to lose his condo. Rain had a little something to say about this scene too, Angela. Let's play this clip. Angela, your reaction, the tiniest hint of the smile of the Lady Macbeth smile that you give Dwight during when he's announcing the few of you that will be left during my reign.
高兴坏了。斯坦利有一堆问题要问。菲利斯问迈克尔有什么打算。凯文则非常担心迈克尔会失去他的公寓。雷恩对这场戏也有话要说，安吉拉。我们放一下这段音频。安吉拉，你的反应，当你宣布“在我的统治下留下的那少数几个人”时，你给德怀特的那一丝极其微小的微笑，那个麦克白夫人的微笑。
I'm going to lead you into the black with ferocity. Your little look there is fantastic. And Jenna, I love your line about the vacuum cleaner being as capable a manager as Dwight. It was so much fun to shoot. It's so much fun to relive this with you guys. Maybe one day you'll have me actually back on the show again. Maybe the global pandemic has gotten in the way of that a little bit. I'm so glad for what you're doing with this show.
“我将带领你们杀出一条血路，满腔狂热。”你当时的小表情简直绝了。还有詹娜，我太喜欢你关于“吸尘器当经理都比德怀特强”的那句台词了。拍的时候可太好玩了。和你们一起重温这些回忆真的太好玩了。也许有一天你们会真的邀请我回到节目里来。虽然全球大流行稍微阻碍了这一点。我太高兴你们能做这个播客了。
I'm so happy, even though I haven't heard any of the episodes. And I probably never will, but I'm really happy for you because I like you both and you seem like you're having fun. That's all I have to say. I love you both. Goodbye. Oh, rain. That made me laugh.
我太开心了，尽管我一集都没听过。而且我可能永远也不会听，但我真的替你们高兴，因为我喜欢你们俩，而且你们看起来玩得很开心。我要说的就这些。我爱你们俩。再见。哦，雷恩。把我给逗笑了。
You guys, that is rain in a nutshell. He is our curmudgeon with a big heart and I love him so much. I love him so much. We're going to figure this out and we're going to get him on. Yes, rain. I love you. You tall, geeky, man you. But this is true, Angela.
各位，这就是典型的雷恩。他就是我们那个刀子嘴豆腐心的老顽固，我太爱他了。我太爱他了。我们会想办法的，一定要把他请到节目里来。没错，雷恩。我爱妳。你这个高高瘦瘦、书呆子气的男人。不过话说回来，这是真的，安吉拉。
I love how delighted your character is by this new shift in power. I love that when you're alone and you guys talk about it, he tells you that you can be in control of the women and you're very pleased about that as well. Well, this now starts a series of talking heads, right? Because everyone is reacting to this news. I am, of course, delighted. My character's delighted. So Phyllis has a talking head that I love so much, right?
我太喜欢你的角色对权力交替的这种狂喜了。我喜欢当你们独处、讨论这事时，他告诉你由你来管女职员，对此你也感到非常满意。好吧，接下来是一连串的单人访谈，对吧？因为每个人都在对这个消息做出反应。我当然是欣喜若狂了。我的角色乐开了花。所以菲利斯有一个单人访谈我超级喜欢，对吧？
She says, maybe I'll quit. But if you look at the deleted scenes, this goes on for a bit and this is such a great line. Oh, yes, Angela. Yes, yes. Share this, share this. Okay, so she says that her fiance says after they get married, she doesn't even need to work anymore, that her new job is going to be being Mrs. Bob Vance, the first lady of
她说：“也许我要辞职了。”但如果你去看删减片段，这段话其实还持续了一会儿，这台词太棒了。哦，是的，安吉拉。没错，没错。分享一下，分享一下。好的，所以她说她未婚夫说过等他们结婚后，她甚至都不用工作了，她的新工作将是当“鲍勃·万斯太太”，万斯冷气公司的
Vance's refrigeration. Yes, I love that so much. It was so, so cute. And by the way, you see her play that role, like you see her take on being the first lady of Vance's refrigeration as this relationship plays out over the series. Yeah, absolutely. It's really fun to watch. And at 15 minutes, 50 seconds now, we have that Dwight tells Angela that she can be in
第一夫人。是的，我太爱这个梗了。真的超级超级可爱。而且顺便说一句，你看着她把这个角色演活了，随着剧集的推进，你看着她真正担负起了“万斯冷气公司第一夫人”的职责。对，绝对的。看她演这个真的太逗了。然后在15分50秒，德怀特告诉安吉拉她可以负责管理女职员。
charge of the women. Yes. She's a little annoyed because I think she was like, we can do so many great things here. And he's like, there can only be one person in charge. But then as soon as he gives her a job, that she gets to have control over people, she's okay with it. Okay, fine. Yeah, fine.
是的。她其实有点恼火，因为我觉得她本想说“我们在这里可以干出一番大事业”，而德怀特却说“只能有一个人说了算”。但只要他一给她派个能让她对别人发号施令的差事，她就没意见了。好吧，行吧。对，行吧。
She accepts that. I'll be in charge of the women. I remember doing the scene and I was kind of struggling with that final look and of what my expression was and Greg gave me direction. He said, Angela, I want you to imagine what you'll do to the other women. Oh my God. That was the look I had. That's amazing.
她接受了这个。我来负责管理女职员。我记得在拍那场戏时，我对最后那个眼神以及我当时的面部表情到底该怎么拿捏有点拿不准，于是格雷格给了我指导。他说：“安吉拉，我想象一下你打算怎么对付其他女职员。”天哪。我当时就是带着那个表情。太绝了。
That is amazing. So now we're back at Fancy Stamford and Karen is making fun of Jim's lack of call of duty skills, right? He's not very good at it, but she's just sort of smiling through it and just, she's clearly a little smitten, Sam. Blurty Karen. Yeah. I talked to my mom about it.
那简直太绝了。好了，现在我们切回高大上的斯坦福分部，凯伦正在嘲笑吉姆那烂透了的《使命召唤》技术，对吧？他游戏玩得不怎么样，但她只是微微一笑，很明显她已经有点心动了，萨姆。陷入爱河的凯伦。对。我跟我妈聊过这事。
I talked to Birdie Kinsey. Birdie said, that's Flurty Karen. Oh, Angela, I love it so much. I love it that you made your mom say Flurty Karen. It took a minute. I had to explain everything. She was like, what am I doing? And then I told her what Karen was up to and she said, well, she is being flirty.
伯蒂（Birdie）说：“那是陷入爱河的凯伦。”哦，安吉拉，我太爱了。我太喜欢你让你妈说出“陷入爱河的凯伦”了。花了好一会儿工夫。我得把前因后果解释给她听。她问：“我在干嘛呢？”然后我告诉她凯伦在搞什么鬼，她说：“好吧，她确实是在调情。”
So this is Flurty Karen, guys. Karen is putting on the flirt. Yes. This is what I was talking about in my fast fact. This is what got everybody very, very, very upset. Yes. And then on a side note, Rashida said in the DVD commentary that this was her audition scene.
所以这就是“调情的凯伦”，伙计们。凯伦正在调情。是的。这就是我在快速事实里提到的。这就是让每个人都非常非常非常生气的。是的。然后顺便说一句，拉什达在DVD评论里说过，这就是她的试镜场景。
Oh, really? This was a scene she had to audition with. So she really knew this scene well. Well, I want you to know something. This is jumping ahead a little bit, but I just want to say to wrap up this storyline of the Jim Karen flirt. You know, at the end of this, when Jim is packing up for the night and Karen's watching and he throws the fake grenade at her, this is now kind of like their first inside joke.
哦，真的吗？这就是她试镜要演的场景。所以她对这个场景真的很熟。好吧，我想让你们知道一件事。这有点提前了，但我只想为吉姆和凯伦的调情这条故事线做一个总结。你知道，在这集快结束时，吉姆在收拾东西准备下班，凯伦在一旁看着，然后他向她扔了一个假手雷，这现在有点像他们之间的第一个内部笑话。
That scene was not in the script. That was added later. We saw that Karen is kind of sweet on Jim a little bit, right? In the scene you're talking about. But they wanted to see Jim give her a little helper. Yeah. They wanted to see a little bit go her way. And so they added that scene to show that there was a real connection between them.
那个场景不在剧本里。那是后来加的。我们看到凯伦对吉姆有点好感，对吧？在你刚才说的那个场景里。但他们想看到吉姆给她一点帮助。是的。他们想看到事情对她有利一点。所以他们加入了那个场景，以表明他们之间有着真正的联系。
A playfulness, if you will. Well, it worked. We have to talk about the most uncomfortable groveling I've ever witnessed. And rain in true rain fashion, 18 minutes, 25 seconds begins to beg. Beg Michael. And Michael is just watching him. He gets on the ground. He kind of shoves his butt in the air, then he lays flat on the ground.
如果你愿意的话，这是一种开玩笑。好吧，这成功了。我们得谈谈我见过的最让人尴尬的卑躬屈膝。雷恩以他特有的方式，在18分25秒开始哀求。哀求迈克尔。而迈克尔就这么看着他。他趴在地上。他把屁股翘到半空中，然后整个人平躺在地上。
And then at 19 minutes, 11 seconds, Jenna, Jenna, the drool. Yeah. We got letters about the drool, Angela. Letters about the drool. It is so disgusting. It comes out, then he sucks it back in, then he kind of swallows it, then he hugs Michael hard. Yeah.
然后在19分11秒，珍娜，珍娜，口水。是的。我们收到了关于口水的信件，安吉拉。关于口水的信件。太恶心了。口水流出来了，然后他又把它吸了回去，接着他好像把它咽了下去，然后紧紧地抱住了迈克尔。是的。
So all that stuff on the ground and the hugging and all of that, that was all scripted. The drool was just on the day. That was... Yeah. There was no scripted drool. All rain. But rain is right in his little clip when he said it's the seabring that breaks Michael. It is so brilliant when he's like, take it back.
所以地上所有的那些动作、拥抱以及所有这些，都是剧本里写好的。口水完全是即兴的。那是……是的。剧本里可没有口水。全都是雷恩即兴发挥的。但雷恩在他的小片段里说得对，正是赛百灵（Sebring）击垮了迈克尔。当他说“收回它”的时候，简直太精彩了。
That's my car. Yes. Yes. Oh my gosh, well, you know when Michael tells Dwight to stand up and hug it out, bitch? We had a fan question from Kristen Bauer. She said, that line, hug it out, bitch, is one of my favorite lines in the whole show and it cracks me up. Who came up with that line?
那是我的车。没错。没错。哦天哪，你知道迈克尔让德怀特站起来“拥抱一下，碧池”是什么时候吗？我们收到了克里斯汀·鲍尔（Kristen Bauer）的粉丝提问。她说，那句台词“拥抱一下，碧池”是整部剧里她最喜欢的台词之一，让她笑得不行。谁想出这句台词的？
Well, Kristen, this is a famous line from the show Entourage, which we set up earlier that Michael loves, Jeremy Piven's character Ari Gold would say it all the time. This was in the script. This was a callback and I got curious about it though, Angela, and I watched an interview last night with Jeremy Piven and he said he was talking about improvisation on the set of Entourage and he said, we really did not improvise. We really didn't. He said it was very, very, very, very rare to improvise.
好吧，克里斯汀，这是剧集《明星伙伴》（Entourage）里的名台词，我们之前提到过迈克尔很喜欢这部剧，杰瑞米·皮文（Jeremy Piven）饰演的角色阿里·戈尔德（Ari Gold）经常这样说。这句台词写在剧本里。这是一个前后呼应，不过安吉拉，我对此产生了好奇，昨晚我看了一个杰瑞米·皮文的采访，他说他在谈论《明星伙伴》片场的即兴表演时表示，他们其实并没有怎么即兴发挥。他们真的没有。他说即兴发挥是非常非常非常罕见的。
But he said, occasionally they did and the thing about improvisation he was saying was like, if you are in your character, then you will say something that your character would say. It's not about necessarily trying to be funny or clever. It's just about saying that next thing that your character would honestly say in the moment. He said that the line, hug it out, bitch, was an improvisation. This famous line, he said it was crazy because we rarely did it, but there was this scene that he was in and his character was trying to comfort another character and so he just
但他说，偶尔他们也会这么做。关于即兴表演，他的意思是，如果你完全进入了角色，那么你就会说出符合你角色身份的话。这不一定是为了搞笑或显得聪明。这只是说出你的角色在当时那一刻本能会说的下一句话。他说，“拥抱一下，碧池”这句台词就是即兴发挥。这句名台词，他说太疯狂了，因为他们很少这么做，但他当时正处于一个场景中，他的角色试图安慰另一个角色，所以他只是
improvised, let's hug it out, bitch. Isn't that crazy? I love that that was an improvised line because it sums up his character Ari just perfectly. This is an amazing callback which I love as an improviser. I know, Rain, if you're listening, you're making fun of me right now. But as an improviser, I live for a callback. So I love that they set up Entourage at the beginning and they bring this subtle reference back at the end.
即兴说出了“我们拥抱一下吧，碧池”。不是很疯狂吗？我喜欢这句即兴台词，因为它完美地概括了他的角色阿里。这是一个惊人的前后呼应，作为一个即兴演员，我非常喜欢。我知道，雷恩，如果你在听的话，你现在一定在笑话我。但作为一名即兴演员，我为了前后呼应而活。所以我很喜欢他们在开头铺垫了《明星伙伴》，并在结尾把这个微妙的梗带了回来。
Well, now the episode really wraps up with Michael and Dwight. They're back in the conference room. They're watching a movie together. Angela, you walk by, you're not pleased. But listen, this is how it had to be. He chose Michael once again. I feel like Dwight is torn between Angela and Michael for years. And then finally it goes her way because he leaves.
好吧，现在这一集在迈克尔和德怀特的互动中真正收尾了。他们回到了会议室。他们一起看电影。安吉拉，你走过时，看起来很不高兴。但听着，事情只能这样。他再次选择了迈克尔。我觉得德怀特多年来一直在安吉拉和迈克尔之间左右为难。最后事情终于如了她的愿，因为他要走了。
Well, Michael has his final talking head where he says they hugged it out. He's still angry, so he did make Dwight stand in the middle of the office with a sign around his neck that says Liar. And Dwight has to do Michael's laundry for a year. And that's where we leave it. Before we wrap up, I have two little things to share with you guys. I did write in my journal about this episode and I only wrote about one thing. All right, so Jenna, I wrote that I did a different talking head that didn't make it
好吧，迈克尔最后对着镜头说他们拥抱过了。他还是很生气，所以他确实让德怀特站在办公室中间，脖子上挂着一个写着“骗子”的牌子。而且德怀特还要帮迈克尔洗一年的衣服。故事就在这里结束了。在我们结束之前，我有两件小事想和大家分享。我确实在这集的日记里写了些东西，而且我只写了一件事。好吧，珍娜，我写到我拍了一个不同的采访镜头，但没有被剪进
in the show. And I said, I thought it was so funny, but maybe it was just too long. But Angela Martin says that she has a friend who has introduced her to a show called Star Trek. And in Star Trek, there is a guy named Spock and he's very honorable and brave. And he stands up for what he thinks is right. And she just wishes that someone in the office could be more like Spock. And I just thought it was really cute that it's a window into their lives that Dwight
正片里。我说我觉得太搞笑了，但可能只是太长了。但安吉拉·马丁说她有一个朋友向她介绍了一部名叫《星际迷航》的剧。在《星际迷航》里，有一个叫史波克的人，他非常正直和勇敢。他坚持他认为正确的事情。她只是希望办公室里能有人更像史波克一点。我只是觉得这很可爱，这是他们生活的一个窗口，德怀特
is teaching her about Star Trek and what she'd never heard of Star Trek. Yeah. But it's this little show you probably have not heard of it called Star Trek. Here it is. So that deleted scene is not on the DVD extras, guys. I don't know where that lives, but I did a whole talking head about Star Trek. But there is a deleted scene I have to share with you and I will leave you with this, Jenna. This is on the DVD extras.
正在向她讲述《星际迷航》以及她从未听说过的《星际迷航》。是的。但这只是个你可能没听说过的小节目，叫《星际迷航》。就是这样。所以那个被删减的场景不在DVD花絮里，伙计们。我不知道它在哪里，但我拍了一整段关于《星际迷航》的采访镜头。不过有一个被删减的场景我必须和大家分享，我最后要把这个留给你，珍娜。这在DVD花絮里。
We find out that Creed sleeps under his desk four nights a week and then he goes to his place in Toronto. Yeah. What? I love that. What? When I was rereading the script, I read that and I actually remember Creed shooting that and it was so funny.
我们发现克里德一周有四个晚上睡在办公桌底下，然后他会去他在多伦多的住所。是的。什么？我太喜欢这个了。什么？当我重新看剧本时，我读到了这一段，我其实还记得克里德拍摄那一幕的情景，太搞笑了。
And I remember Paul cracking up while they were shooting that because he was so tickled by the idea that Creed slept under his desk. Yeah. So this is why he doesn't have a refrigerator. Oh my God. He's never had his own. He's never had his own refrigerator. He's never had his own refrigerator because he sleeps under his desk four nights a week.
我还记得保罗在拍摄时笑得前仰后合，因为克里德睡在办公桌底下的这个想法把他逗乐了。是的。所以这就是为什么他没有冰箱。哦，天哪。他从来没有过自己的冰箱。他从来没有过自己的冰箱。他从来没有过自己的冰箱，因为他一周有四个晚上都睡在办公桌底下。
I love it. And then what is his whole second life in Toronto? I am so intrigued. Guys, that was the coup. We love that you are sticking with us and continuing to listen to this podcast. It is a joy for us to make it. Thank you again to Rainn Wilson for sending us your audio. If you want to hear more of Rainn's sexy voice, you can listen to his podcast Metaphysical
我太喜欢了。那他在多伦特的双重生活到底是怎样的？我太好奇了。伙计们，这就是政变（指本集标题The Coup）。我们很高兴你们能一直陪伴我们并继续收听这个播客。录制这个节目对我们来说是一种快乐。再次感谢雷恩·威尔逊发给我们你的音频。如果你想听到更多雷恩性感的嗓音，你可以听他的播客《Metaphysical》
Milkshake with Rainn and Reza Aslan. Yes, they are discussing life's big human questions with heart, humor and curiosity. Stuff like life, death, love, fate, beauty, you name it. It is available on the Luminary Podcast platform. Rainn, we're going to get you back on here. We're going to get glitchy up in here, Rainn. We're going to get glitchy up in here, Rainn. Thank you so much for sending in your questions and your comments and your deep dives.
《Milkshake with Rainn and Reza Aslan》。是的，他们带着热情、幽默和好奇心探讨了人生中的重大问题。比如生命、死亡、爱、命运、美，应有尽有。它可以在 Luminary 播客平台上收听。雷恩，我们会把你请回来的。我们要在这里搞点故障特效了，雷恩。我们要在这里搞点故障特效了，雷恩。非常感谢你们发来问题、评论和深入探讨。
We love you guys so much. We'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
我们太爱你们了。我们下周见。感谢收听 Office Ladies。《Office Ladies》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是阿恩斯利·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Rubber Tree》。
For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要收听无广告版本的《Office Ladies》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。在 Stitcher Premium 上免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码：OFFICE。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。